ich will ein neues handy vor drei jahren
hatte die kieler im supermarkt vergessen
ja weil du die ganze zeit auf dein handy
geguckt habe in den letzten tagen mal
wieder das internet durchstöbert habt
ihr guckt was unsere lieblings
ratgeberserie suppe videos produziert
und habe ich eine folge gesehen und habe
mir gedacht es kann eigentlich nicht
sein ist der tag gekommen an dem hilft
mir ein video produziert über eine sache
die zumindest zu einem hundertstel echt
ist wenn man sich die antwort könnte man
das denken denn es geht um das video
smoby mein handy ist alles für mich also
es geht können sie im handy sucht und
ich habe mit meiner langjährigen
erfahrung natürlich die absolute
erwartung dass sich diese folge einiges
bringen wird legen wir los
okay das ist das erste bild was gesehen
wir haben ja eine junge dame auf einem
fahrrad und sie hat hinter sich ein
anhänger in dem vermutlich ihrer tochter
sitzt und natürlich wie es eine gute
mutter so macht sie auf ihr eigenes
leben und voll das leben ihrer tochter
und schaut aufs handy beim fahrradfahren
ok ok super leute werden gleich mehrere
erkenntnis in diesem video will ja nicht
nur wie man optimale mit der eigenen
handy sucht umgeht sondern auch wie man
die perfekte mutter ist und auf jeden
fall dafür sorgt dass das eigene kind
binnen kürzester zeit bei einem
verkehrsunfall stirbt aus kindlicher
einem umgekippten fahrer anhänger
wahrscheinlich die wirbelsäule drei mal
probiert also wie das kind sieht nicht
gut aus verrät es sieht nicht gut aus
und das erste was die macht ist es war
noch mehr in die show
kleine rote sagt man tut etwas weh was
tut ihr denn weh du auch an der stelle
muss ich sagen man kann der jungen dame
nichts vorwerfen das eigene kind ist
zwar tödlich verletzt aber sie macht
trotzdem das richtige und schaut erst
mal ein youtube-video vermehrt neue hast
du gemeint du das sieht aber auch bös
aus du sag mal ist das deine schwester
also ich weiß ändert eigentlich auch
nicht wirklich was sagt mal kannst du
vielleicht ein arzt anrufen
hallo ich spreche mit dir hallo sagen
sie jetzt von der seite hier der mensch
du kannst doch jetzt nicht da mit dem
handy rumspielen wisst ihr was wir dabei
denke leute ich glaube so sehen unsere
eltern uns also ich weiß ja nicht
verleiten ist könnte man die kommentare
schreiben
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass es
viele eltern gibt die genauso ihre
kinder sehen so nach dem motto neben dem
kind keine atombombe einschlagen egal da
ins programm entdecken viett muss erst
mal abgeschickt werden diese junge
damals schon wieder recht heute was soll
ich sagen
der grund dafür dass wir keine schwester
gerade eben fast ums leben gekommen ist
ist natürlich der alte mann der sie
dabei gestört hat whatsapp nachrichten
zu schreiben
richtige mexiko das darf doch nicht wahr
sein guck mal deine schwester ist
verletzt und ein handy funktioniert dort
noch das ja die schwester funktioniert
auch noch oder ist die schwester
gesprungen
nein es ist handy gesprochen ja das
lässt hoffen doch gut an gesichter
kleiner schwester erkennen wie sie ihre
große schwester anschaut und sich denkt
mensch hätte man sich mal lieber
abgetrieben
klar sie haben mich so erschrocken dass
ich hingefallen bin dass es überhaupt
allein es ihre schuld
okay ich habe alles ist was ich gesagt
habe von wegen sinnvolle ratgebersendung
ok und dass diese eine folge uns
vielleicht etwas bringen kann
es ist genau dasselbe trotz wie immer du
hast nur eins im kopf nämlich nur dein
handy
das geht sie sowieso überhaupt nichts
anders machen was ich will was ist ihre
schulter und ich will das geld haben
komm her was wir sehen sind schlagen
außerdem steht da schon direkt vor dem
ok das kind verletzt wird dann hört das
auf damit es nicht zum im geld und auch
nichts mit dem handy dann hat das kind
vorsorge
das hat das problem mit der
elterngeneration der noch nicht ganz
verstanden dass kinder nachwachsen sich
selbst heilen kann ja ein teil des
verlorenen kind zeugen der wenn das
eigene kind mal keine ahnung wenn man
aus versehen den föhn in die badewanne
fallen lässt bis eigentlich hin badet
werden gerade auch ins du wirst du hast
nur eins im kopf dein blödes handy aber
anstatt dass du dich mal jetzt um deine
schwester kümmert was sagst du da ist
alles in ordnung
lasst uns morgen die leute ihre mutter
ist auch so ziehen die schweiz
das geht nicht ganz kurz übrigens auch
in der praxis eine wortneuschöpfung eine
kombination aus smartphone und zombie
also menschen den sie wie zombies
behalten weil sie in smartphone bedienen
[Musik]
habe eben einen unfall einen kleinen und
dann bin ich hingefallen und mein handy
ist mir aus der tasche gefallen wie du
hattest ein unfall war kann ich jetzt
bitte können wir nicht los weil die
geschäfte haben ist auch nicht mehr so
lange ja meine kleine schwester ist
droht aber jetzt war nicht so schlecht
nein darum geht es nicht wie du siehst
ist ein sprung in meinem bildschirm und
ansonsten ist nichts passiert und ich
sehe ist alles okay ja lass mich da erst
mal kochen jetzt ja was heißt das für
die reaktion sie sagt sie hat ein unfall
das ihr handy kaputt ist das ist
reparieren will und die mutter wir
kochen ist dass das was mit den ganzen
tag machen wollen danach kannst du ich
möchte jetzt erstmal koch typische
mutter habe eine rettung an alle jungen
schwimmkräne baby ist schon gut aus oder
[Musik]
ich habe ich komme von der arbeit ich
möchte kochen ist ja ne ist alles okay
bei dir dass das hängst besonderes man
das macht mir spaß mich fast umgebracht
hast du dir weh getan ganz kurz bevor
die mutter ausrastet ich weiß nicht ob
es richtig ist kinder erhielten wir
folgende auftauchen zu lassen ich meine
selbst bei erwachsenen ist
keine gute idee aber irgendjemand ist
der vater die mutter von diesem kind und
hat gesagt natürlich noch mein kind bei
der hilfe erfolge mit sorgerecht bitte
sofort entziehen
[Musik]
ich möchte wirklich wieder mal wie ich
einfach beim schrauben dieser folge
komplett verblödet aber über so was
redet ja keine in deutschland da die
ganzen politiker
zigaretten sind ungesund alkohol ist
ungesund die avastin hier
ich bekomme von der scheiße hier noch
ein hirntumor ist nicht ungesund das ist
ja so als würde ich mich mit dem
vorgängermodell blicken lassen
damit kann ich mich einfach nirgendwo
blicken lassen können uns auf einigen
oder es ist natürlich das peinlichste
aller zeiten noch peinlicher als
beispielsweise nacht durch die
innenstadt laufen zu müssen aber mit
einem vorgängermodell des aktuellen
smartphones entdeckt wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einfahren fall müssten dorfmann hast du
mir kein wort gesagt variieren dabei
ja aber da konnte ich doch nichts für
die funktioniert doch was soll der geiz
sagen ist doch schon wieder aber ganz
leichtes wissen gemein von ihrer mutter
so glück schon wieder genau wie vor drei
jahren war einmal eine drei jahre davon
nicht lügen oder wie sebastian lust den
möglich ausgebracht genau wie damals vor
13 jahren
okay was habe ich da gemacht habe ich
sie hat eben wirklich vor allem
millisekunde auch nur verteidigt ich
nehme alles zurück leute die lust hat
ihre kleine schwester im supermarkt
vergessen
da schenkt ihre volle aufmerksamkeit
unglaublich gerne her aber wem genau nur
dem handy das heißt sie ist fixiert
darauf sie braucht das dass es fast
schon ein suchtverhalten was ich hier
sehe aber nur fast
das konsumverhalten sollte man an der
show noch nicht sprechen wenn die
schwere verletzung oder tod von enke
familie mit ihr in kauf genommen wird
für ein bisschen mehr screentime fast
fast sucht du hast vergessen wird ins
tote glaube ich wenn man einen menschen
der für sein eigenes handy so auf seine
eigene schwester scheint dieses handy
dann wegnimmt
könnte es sein dass die mutter das ende
dieser folge nicht erlebt es ist immer
das gleiche
warum ist jedes verdammte hilft mir
freude gleich aufgebaut
es passiert irgendwie scheiße man denkt
sich so menschheit ist verloren und dann
wird immer verwendet blitz einschlägt
und der atomkrieg losgeht wird die
nächste szene immer sein dass die person
bei der arbeit irgend einer freundin
oder einem freund verzieht ganz ehrlich
ich glaube ja bei rtl 2 eine schablone
verhelfen wir folgen nehmen die so immer
gleich aufgebaut und gießen dann einfach
irgendein geistes kann inhalt rein und
haben schon wieder ein video
echtes auf science haben voll viele es
cool das ist natürlich das wichtigste
bei dem handy dass man voll viele apps
darauf hat ganz ehrlich wie zeiler ich
habe schon wieder so 50 jährige
ausgedacht oder das zweite an dieser
folge leute ich habe wieder mega prima
trial übrig deswegen kommt der zweite
teil jährigen morgen für euch pakistan
gerne hier noch einfach persönlich vom
scheidungs video ab und bleibt tapfer